MALE SPEAKER: There are
basically seven billion people.
And if you made a big
pyramid about who's
been undersea the
most, in submarines
the most, gone the deepest,
gone to the most places,
has the most unusual stories,
at the very top there's one
person.
And that's Don.
So it's pretty rare
that literally one
in seven billion people
come to talk to you.
And something I've noticed
about people like that is they
tend to be very modest in how
they explain their background.
So they say things like,
we once saw that so-and-so,
but they don't mention
that's when they were
at the bottom of
the Marianas Trench,
or that's when they
were at The Bismarck,
or that's when they were picked
by two different presidents
to advise on science policy.
Or why the State Department
goes to them for advice,
or why they're the dean of
a school of ocean science,
things like that.
They also don't tend
to tell you things
about their accomplishments
that have been rewarded
because they're too modest.
DON WALSH: My wife tells me I've
got a lot to be modest about.
MALE SPEAKER:
Well, there you go.
But I'll tell you two of
them, just because they're
really impressive to me.
One is the United States
Navy only likes Navy people.
It's very rare for them
to say that somebody who's
not in the Navy, like in
the Marines, or the Army,
or like a civilian,
did something useful.
But Don has won the highest
possible award from the Navy
for civilian service and
military service to the Navy.
Also even more impressive
to me personally,
he won the Hubbard award
from the National Geographic
Society, which is
what you get when
you climb Mount Everest
for the first time.
Or go to the moon, or
something like that.
In his case, it was going
the other direction,
climbing down Mount
Everest, so to speak,
to the bottom of
Marianas Trench.
Because I hope when
you listen to him
you'll realize that
everything he says
represents the integration
of all the world's knowledge
on these topics better than
anyone else on the planet.
Thank you, Don.
DON WALSH: Are
there any questions?
Thank you.
That was most generous.
I'm glad to be here,
of course I think
it's every kid's dream, even
before Google was invented,
to visit a place like
this because there's
so much cerebral popcorn
here just walking around.
And what a grand place to work.
I'm not a very good
institutional person,
so I can appreciate
non-institutional frameworks.
And so it's really
grand to be here.
Today I just want to
give you a little talk.
Now some of you will say,
well, it's just history.
Telling a nice sea story
about where I've been
or what we've done, the early
exploration of the oceans.
But I think you folks could
really appreciate the notion
that the whole march of
technology and engineering--
that's my basic
background, engineering--
is to move the decimal point.
Things that are
laboratory curiosities
30 years ago or 10 years ago,
we have to keep revisiting them.
Because some of them might
be possible to transition
into operations or
marketplace, depending
on where you're moving.
So when I subtitle this
and print it out for you,
Looking Backwards at
the Future, that's
the notion I had in mind.
We're going to go back and
look at the very beginning
of manned exploration
inside the sea.
Basically taking
the trained mind
and the trained eye
into the environment.
And I say personal odyssey.
That's a bit precious, I know.
But our first hydronaut, if
you will, first man of sea,
was professor William
Beebe, 1930-1934.
And I came into this about '57.
So I've sort of been in this
field for 2/3 of its lifetime.
Personal odyssey.
I didn't do all this stuff, but
it was a pretty small field.
In fact when I had
command of the Trieste,
the French Navy had an
equivalent Bathyscaph.
And If we wanted to talk about
engineering, and technology,
and operational skills
to explore the deep ocean
with these manned platforms,
we could book a table
in a restaurant for about 10
people and they'd all be there.
It's kind of bigger now, but
that was in the very beginning.
We had to write the book.
If you want something you had
to design it and either build it
or have somebody build it.
There were no catalogues, or
vendors, or any of this stuff.
So we can see today
all of our fingerprints
on almost everything.
Underwater manipulators.
First ROV ever built
was for the Trieste.
The first underwater manipulator
we bought from General Mills,
believe it or not.
And OK, yes, all of the
O-rings were Cheerios.
But all of that stuff.
Not because we were
smarter or anything else,
but if you wanted it
you had to build it.
So that's where I started out.
And I worked with Jacques
Cousteau, made some programs
with him on Calypso.
Hans Hass, a very famous
underwater diver of the '50s
and '60s, I knew
him and all that.
So this was my crew
as I grew up in this
as a lieutenant in the US
Navy coming out of submarines.
There's this whole world of
these really interesting people
down at Scripps and
throughout the world.
And we had what the lawyers
call an attractive nuisance.
That's when you don't put a
fence around your swimming pool
and a neighbor kid falls
in and you get sued.
And the legal
principle is you've
created an attractive nuisance.
So the Trieste in some way
was an attractive nuisance.
We had, I think the
three years I was there,
four Nobel laureates come
in and have a look at it
for no other reason
they were curious.
It was a very yeasty
world that we came from.
And I'm delighted
that for 53, 54 years
I've been able to work
in it continuously.
So that's a personal Odyssey.
I probably leaned on
that button too long.
Here's the essential problem.
What's down there?
How do we see it?
And you can see
it all right here.
That is the nature
of the question.
Because the surface of
the ocean is opaque,
we can't look into it.
I remember-- and I can't
find the damn thing.
I want to put in my program.
It's a Dennis the Menace
cartoon by Hank Ketcham,
and shows Dennis and Little
Joey standing there looking out
at the ocean.
The view is from behind them.
And they're holding
hands like this,
and Dennis is saying, yeah,
there's a lot more under there.
And that's the idea.
From the beginning
of oceanography
as a multidisciplinary
science about 1870,
that was the
Challenger expedition.
The Royal Society sent HMS
Challenger around the world
with scientists.
I think it was a
three-year expedition.
Two plus.
And they did a heroic
amount of collecting.
In fact, a lot of the
specimens are still
being looked at in the 50 volume
report from the expedition.
But they were at the interface.
They lowered artificial
hands in the ocean,
scooped up stuff and tried
to describe the ocean
from crushed bits of
sediment or organisms.
Then didn't even
have artificial eyes,
which we had later in
the form of cameras.
But why not take
the trained mind
the trained eye into
the environment?
Because that's how
we do field sciences.
Biology and geology, you go
into the field and you observe.
As a biologist you observe the
critter that interests you,
but also how it interacts
with this environment.
That's very important.
And a geologist has to sort
of look at the land form
before you take a
selected sample out.
And the same thing
with a biologist.
We've never done
that in oceanography.
We've done it like this.
It's like flying over New Mexico
in a balloon on a dark night
and lowering down a grappling
hook and pull stuff out,
and then defining what is
down there in that land mass.
It's Gila monsters and firemen
and maybe in an odd VW Bug.
And then you get a
learned paper in Monaco
about the nature
of this new land.
Terra New Mexico.
I'm exaggerating.
I think you probably
gathered that.
But the notion of being able
to take the trained mind,
trained eye into the
ocean, very important.
Now if you're a chemist or
physical oceanographer, which
is my field, not so important.
A chemist can't look at
water and decide what it is.
You've got to do certain
analytical things.
But for the observational
sciences, very important.
Now that's my parish notices.
Let's go with the program here.
OK, I've introduced you
to doctor William Beebe.
1930-34 he made the first
voyages into the abyss.
1934 he made a dive
to a half mile down.
And for those of you who
are really keen on history
of science and
exploration, you can still
get a copy of "Half Mile Down"
at an antiquarian bookstores.
They're not very
expensive because he
was a prolific writer.
He was kind of the
Carl Sagan of his time.
A talented scientist, but so he
also knew how to tell a story.
In fact, what he
was was something
that's very rare today,
and that's a naturalist.
If you look back in the
history of science, especially
in the late 19th
century, the naturalists
were the people
that knew something
about the plants, the
animals, the geology.
And they could draw
because of course they
didn't have cameras then.
And so they were kind
of all-purpose people.
Very useful on expeditions.
They could run, pass, and punt.
And Beebe was of that world.
As a trained naturalist
he started out with birds,
and he did this work
in the deep ocean,
and at the end of his life he
was working on butterflies.
And so he was the ever curious
guy and he could write.
And his books were very popular.
He was very popular on
the speaking circuit.
He made quite a
bit of money and he
bought Nonsuch Island
in the Bahamas.
And that's where
they did this dive,
at his island that
he bought, he owned.
And it was a remarkable
thing, "Half Mile Down",
in 1934, when commercial diving,
hard hat diving and such,
maybe they're getting
down to 600 feet by then.
But it was very experimental,
"Half Mile Down".
So if you're interested in
such things, get the book.
You've got his
illustrations in there.
Don't wait for the
movie to come out
because that's not
going to happen.
John Wayne's gone.
So that was William Beebe,
a giant in our field.
The one thing I'll
mention here, and that
is the viewports he
used were made out
of fused quartz, something
that General Electric had just
developed.
It's a crystal, and
made out of that.
And we have a gentleman in
this room-- where's Chris?
There he is.
His Virgin Oceanic submersible
uses a fused quartz dome.
The only man to do it
in nearly a century.
Well done.
I'm sure that you know
something the rest of us
don't know about acrylic.
Well, there it is.
If you have questions
about his subject,
you'll meet it in my program.
You can ask the guy
over there in the corner
Auguste Piccard was a physicist.
He was of the crew, if
you will, of Einstein
or even Madame Curie
was still alive
when he started
out as a physicist.
And there's a
wonderful picture that
was in Jacques Piccard's
office of a physicist meeting.
In Lausanne, I think, about
1920, and they're all there.
So he was one the classic
family of physicists
of around that time.
But when he was a student at
Zurich Polytechnic in 1904,
he was ill for a while abed.
And he was a balloon pilot
in the Swiss army reserve.
As you know, all
males in Switzerland
have to belong in
the Army Reserve.
And he was a balloon pilot, and
he was reading these reports
in the Meteor expedition
of the late 1800s,
the German expedition.
All the stuff they were
getting by remote sensing,
again sitting on that
interface grabbing stuff up
from the depths.
And he said, I
wonder why you can't
use the idea of a
balloon to go underwater.
The most fluid media.
You just have to have
something that has payload
and you can make it
descend and come back up.
So that's what you've
been looking at here.
The one on the left
is his Bathyscaph.
Bathy meaning deep,
scaphos, boat.
Deep boat.
And on the right is the balloon
that he was more used to
in flying through the air.
And so he came up
with that concept.
He didn't do much with it.
And it was until 1948,
just after World War II,
that he developed
his Bathyscaph.
FNRS is the French is
the National Research
Foundation of Belgium,
which had sponsored.
FNRS 2, by the way, was
a high-altitude balloon
that Piccard set
a world's record.
1931, 70,000 feet.
The conventional wisdom with
medical doctors associated
with aviation in
1931 is if you went
above 24,000 feet
you'd surely die.
So nobody would build
it, the capsule,
the cabin for his balloon.
So he found a brewery
in Belgium that
would make beer vessels,
vats, containers.
A huge-- like a barrel, OK?
It had a few openings
in it, things like that.
They built it for professor
Piccard, sent it to him.
That became the cabin
for his first balloon.
So he knew balloons and
he set a world's record.
Incidentally, he was
studying cosmic radiation.
So the quintessential scientist.
It was not to set
a record, it was
to get above the masking effect
of the Earth's atmosphere
so you get good numbers.
He tried the Alps, that didn't
work, so he used his balloon.
OK, 1948 he builds
his first Bathyscaph.
Now here we run
into the old problem
between theory and practice.
The theory was pretty good.
I'm sorry.
I'm mastering this thing now.
All right, folks.
I push something.
Push that again.
OK there it is.
He set up with a pressure
switch because, well I'll
make the first
deeper dive with it.
I'll have it drop weight
and come back automatically.
There won't be anybody in it.
So it down to 4,800
feet, came right back up.
So there's the theory.
It works.
Bathyscaph, good stuff.
Here's the cabin,
there's the balloon.
However, it was unseaworthy.
And once it got back
on the surface to
started to come apart.
So practice, not so good.
And those of you in
the front row, you
can see this person right here.
So the French Navy ship that
was set by the National Science
Foundation to kind
of help Piccard,
and that's Lieutenant
Jacques-Yves Cousteau before he
went on to other things.
OK, so that was the
first Bathyscaph.
The foundation said, look
your theory's really great,
Professor Piccard,
but we want you
to get with the French Navy.
Go to the French naval
shipyard in Toulon.
They make submarines,
things like that.
Keep the bits that
are important,
that are robust, the cabin,
and make a new Bathyscaph
that is more seaworthy.
And that's what they did.
Piccard didn't get along
with the French very well.
They got offers from Italy
to build another Bathyscaph,
and so here comes the Trieste.
1953.
Why is a called Trieste?
It was built in the Adriatic
shipyard near Trieste, Italy.
And it was built with all
donated goods and services.
Pirelli provided the
rubber tubing and wiring.
Agip, the national
petroleum company,
provided the buoyancy material,
which I didn't get to.
But this underwater
balloon, of course,
can't use helium or
hydrogen for buoyancy,
that doesn't work underwater.
So oil floats on water, why
not fill it with petroleum?
Aviation gasoline is readily
available throughout the world
and it's a light fraction.
So you get a lot of lift
per volume of gasoline.
And that's what we have.
By the way, the
zebra stripes there
are because remember
this is a balloon.
Yes, it's a thin steel
shell, very thin,
but it still has to have
some-- you know, everything
you add in the way of structure,
it deducts from payload.
Just common in
anything that flies.
So the zebra stripes are
transverse bulkheads.
So if you have to
push it with a boat
or put some pressure on
that very thin shell,
that's where it's strongest.
I'll give you a little bit
on the theory of operation.
To get to go down
you had ballast tanks
here on the bow and the
stern filled with air.
When you tow out to the dive
site, you vent off that air,
it's heavier than water,
and you start down.
Now it's very desirable to
slow down and eventually
stop and come back up.
You have to get rid of weight.
Well, you can't use air like
a regular military submarine
to blow water out
of ballast tanks
because we're talking about
back pressures up to 16,000 PSI.
And that's pretty
tricky with air.
So we have to drop mass weight.
So right here and there
are two ballast tubs.
Each of those tubs is
filled with eight tons
of steel pellets.
Essentially reusable
sandblast, iron or steel.
Very ordinary stuff.
No quality control.
And so we bought that stuff.
And because of no
quality control,
we could have problems because
at the bottom of those tubs
is an opening right
there and there.
That white cylinder you see at
the bottom is an electromagnet.
So when you energize
that magnet the shot's
magnetized and can't fall.
Here's where quality
control comes in.
You don't know what kind
of steel you've got.
Some of it will
become magnetized.
That's not a good idea because
you can't get rid of weight.
So every pound of steel shot we
used in this program for the 3
and 1/2 years I was with
it, we had a rig in the shop
and we'd run every batch of
steel pellets through there,
magnetize it, turn off the
power and if it flowed then
it was OK.
If it didn't flow,
out the back door.
OK and just in case you
have a really bad emergency,
you could drop both tubs.
That'd be 16 tons plus the
weight of these two tubs.
That's the cabin.
This is the water line here
when you're on the surface.
So there's a tube,
if you will, that
goes down through
the balloon here.
The hatch is right there.
The viewport's there.
The whole thickness
is about seven inches
and the viewport is about
seven inches made out
of acrylic plastic.
A truncated cone.
In other words the inner
surface was very small,
almost one eyeball.
The outer surface was
several inches across.
And since plastic does exactly
that under pressure, it flows,
then it's self-seating.
So it's just a metal seat,
no O-rings or anything.
It would just adjust
itself to the conical seat
in the sphere itself.
The sphere was built by
the Krupp works in Germany.
Those of you up front can
see the Krupp logo there.
Little problem on our 16,000
foot dive at Guam-- I'm
getting ahead of my
story a little bit.
When we bought the Trieste
from the Piccards in 1958
and engaged Jacques Piccard
to be the consultant to us,
show us how to maintain
and operate it,
it was only a 20,000
foot submersible.
And we wanted to go deeper.
So we had to increase
the size the balloon
to get more payload because
avgas, aviation gasoline,
compressed by about
13 and 1/2%, it's
more compressible than seawater.
So on the deep dive we lost
quite a bit of buoyancy
just on that compression.
Also we needed a new cabin.
No one in the US bid on the job.
Krupp works said,
we can do it but we
don't have the machines
to forge two hemispheres.
Because normally, in this
kind of construction,
you start with 100% extra.
So if you want an
eight ton sphere
you start with 16 tons of steel.
And because most of the
bad stuff on a forging
is on the outer part,
you machine all at off,
inclusions and so on, until
you get down to the core.
They said, we don't do that.
We know how to do
it, we don't have it.
The Russians came and took away
our machines after the war.
And I understand they were on
a barge sunk in the Baltic.
So those machines are on the
floor of the Baltic somewhere.
But we'll make it
in three pieces.
We know how to do this.
So what you have is sort of
two semi-hemispherical end
cap one with a hatch
in it and the opposing
one with the viewport in it.
And, as you know, a rule of
thumb is where we take out,
say, five pounds of metal by
machining, you sort of putty
that around the opening.
That's just a real
rule of thumb.
So there's a lot more
mass in those two bits.
Then there's a central ring,
which had no openings in it.
So it was just a
straight seven inches.
It has less mass than
the two end caps.
So we're making this dive off of
Guam, we're doing 16,000 feet.
Where we're diving the seawater
temperature is about 84,
and then you're going
down to about-- I
think it was 34 degrees
roughly at the sea floor.
You're soaking in that cold.
So the hull gets very cold.
You come rocketing
back up to the surface.
These two massive end pieces
are expanding very slowly.
The center one's
expanding very fast.
Because folks, that thing was
glued together with acrylic.
Very finely machined, as
only the Germans might do,
seat and then with
acrylic smacked together.
That's why you're
seeing in this diagram
that there's no real bands
on here sort of holding
all the bits together.
It's just all glued together.
As I had one admiral who came
to see us in San Diego, he said,
well how's this
thing held together?
I don't see a flange.
You know, a typical way
two hemispheres flange,
bolts all the way around,
O-rings, all of that.
He says, I don't
see any of that.
I said, well we don't
have them, admiral.
He said, well how
does it fit together?
I said, it's glued.
And he said, lieutenant,
the Navy does not
glue its ships together.
So I said yes sir.
It's just like when my wife, I
get the last word in, yes dear.
So there it is.
There's the cabin.
That's how it works.
We will meet some of this later.
As I said, the Office of
Naval Research purchased it.
It was purchased as
a research platform.
So what Jacques and I
did on the deep dive,
we were the test
pilots to prove out
the platform to
the maximum test.
Make sure it was safe,
that it was reliable,
and that it was efficient for a
platform for ocean scientists.
And only then would
we put them in it.
So it's like Boeing
builds a new airplane,
they don't roll it
over to the terminal
and load it with passengers.
You have test flight
protocols you go through,
and once you sign it
off and hand it over
to the mere mortals.
So our dive was not
a scientific dive.
It was a proof of concept dive.
And people don't
seem to understand
that we didn't
take a lot of data,
or we didn't stay on
the bottom very long.
It's like saying to Wilbur,
well, you only flew a few feet,
you only took one person.
What use is this?
You've got to start somewhere.
And so the Office
of Naval Research
placed this at the Naval
Laboratory in San Diego
so we had deep water nearby.
[INAUDIBLE] knows just
off La Jolla and San Diego
you get down to 4,000 feet
with a very short trip
from the harbor.
So that was a good place
to home port this thing.
And I joined the program, as I
said, as a submarine officer,
serving in a submarine in
San Diego in January of '59.
And the first dive in US
Navy was made the month
before, December.
And of course this
cabin was my office.
I've told you about it.
Arrayed around the window there
are all the hull penetrators
for the various wires
and controls and things
that we needed to control
from inside the sub
to topside sensors and devices.
It was pretty small
as offices go.
This person's leaning up against
the hatch right behind him
and this one is looking
out through the viewport.
And that's all the stuff.
And we don't have actually
the mission equipment.
That's just the stuff we
needed to run the vehicle.
The scientist would bring
all of his own kit with him
and we'd integrate
it and off we'd go.
So I think some of you,
especially in the higher salary
brackets here, probably
have a 35 cubic foot
refrigerator at home.
Next time you reach in
for a bottle of beer,
think of two dudes
working in there.
Piccard was 6'2".
Cousteau used to call, not
entirely affectionately,
double metre, two meters.
And the temperature was about
the same, but you were busy
and you didn't really notice.
And you sort of
dressed for the event.
Shortly after I
got to the project,
I was informed that the plans
with ONR and with the Navy Lab
were to take it out to Guam
and make a dive in the deepest
place in the world ocean.
And my response was probably
the same as yours was.
Say what?
Because this is-- let's
call it around March of '59.
I had the previous November
made a dive in the submarine
that I was serving in San Diego.
A World War II construction
diesel submarine.
We have what we
call a test depth.
That's your maximum
operating depth
you're permitted to go without
filling out a lot of forms.
And it's 300 feet.
We'd do that a lot.
Even when I had
submarine command
I'd always take my boat
down quite frequently
because it's better to
find leaks whether small.
No surprises.
And the crew is
more relaxed going
the maximum possible
depth if you do it a lot.
And so everybody's
better for it.
So I've been to 300 feet.
January I reported
to the Navy Lab.
The following March, I
made a dive in the Trieste
to 4,000 feet.
That's pretty good.
Here I am on the bottom
of the ocean, 4,000 feet.
And our chief scientist said,
Don come on into the office.
And I said OK.
He said, this is what
we think we want to do.
And that's when he
got his say what?
All in capital letters,
exclamation point.
Anyway, we start to tool
up for Challenger Deep
that I told you earlier.
We bought a new cabin,
expanded the balloon, increased
the payload, got all our stuff
packed up, went out to Guam.
Because mother nature is
pretty fortunate in terms
of geography.
We were only about 200
miles from the deepest place
the world ocean, Challenger
Deep in the Marianas Trench.
That had already been proved
by the Brits, the Soviets,
and Scripps.
Especially Scripps.
Once they put the imprimatur
on it, then that was kosher.
So we knew we were going
to the right place.
Most of them didn't
think anybody was ever
going to go there,
but there we were.
We could do it.
We could only tow it
at about five knots,
so it's going to be a bit
of a drama to get it out
to the dive site in
the Pacific Ocean.
A lot of stuff peeling
off, because most
of the operational
equipment's on the outside.
Lights, and cameras, and
batteries, things of this sort.
But it looked like a go.
We could do it.
Get out there and do that.
So we went out to Guam.
Big Navy base there too,
so we had a lot of support.
And we set up our
shop and started
making increasingly
deeper test dives.
You start in the
harbor but 200 feet,
and by November-- I already
told you about that dive,
16,000 feet.
And we stood down for
Christmas holidays,
mostly to get caught up
with all of our repair bills
and all of that and get it
ready for the final plunge.
January of 1960, early January,
we made a dive to 24,000 feet,
everything was working
good so we were a go
and we went out and headed
for the deepest place.
This is kind of fluff, but
there's Marianas Trench there.
And if you took Mount Everest
and you dropped it in there,
you could see you still have
about a mile above Mount
Everest if you drove over there.
Just idea of how
far below sea level
you are here compared to
the height of Mount Everest.
That really doesn't mean much.
This is for the bridge club,
so I put that in there.
And they like ooh, aah.
You're engineers, so
unimpressed by such stuff.
23 January, 1960,
nine hour drive.
it took us about five
hours and some change
to go down because
we didn't know,
really, what was under us.
Our mother ship was a
Navy Destroyer Escort
and we had a tugboat
out from Guam
that towed the Trieste down.
Those of you that
remember-- oh, there
are a few gray hairs in here.
Bald pates.
Remember LORAN?
And if you get on a
baseline of LORAN,
your navigational
information is really bad.
It's kind of like
in Playboy magazine.
The damn page, the staples go
right down through her tummy.
And so you're on the
baseline of LORAN,
you don't know where you are.
And this destroyer we were on
didn't have a depth sounder.
I mean, it had a depth
sounder to keep you
from running into
something, you know,
the side of an island
or a continent.
Maybe 300 or 400
feet under the keel.
That's all you need
for safe navigation.
But we didn't have a
deep sea sounding device.
Seven miles down, we're
not going to find Atlas.
So where are we?
We can't navigate very well.
We know approximately
from Scripps, the Soviets,
and the Brits where it is,
but seawater magnifies.
You've got to be more close
than just waving your arms.
Oh yeah, we'd get some sun
lines, maybe a star at night,
but it wasn't all that good.
So what we do?
Well, innovation.
It's the American
gift, innovation.
We got several hundred
one-pound blocks of TNT,
put fuses in them.
Put a fuse in them
and then you light it,
throw it over the side.
Now the hydrophone on the
fathometer, the depth finder
on the destroyer is just fine.
It can hear a lot of energy.
So bang, it goes off at
the surface of the water.
Start your stopwatch.
When you hear the return
echo then you turn it off.
12 seconds is deeper
than six seconds.
We don't know on an absolute
basis how deep ocean was,
but we knew we were
in the right place
as long as they had the
longest time return.
That's pretty good.
We finally mapped it out about a
mile wide and seven miles long,
and then put the Trieste in the
middle of that, made the dive
and it seemed to work.
Because we did get
the deepest place.
Even Jim Cameron
couldn't do that good.
I got him by 85 feet still.
So down we went, five hours
and some change going down.
Because again, sea
mounts, things like that.
We don't know outcrops,
didn't want to crash.
And we got to the bottom and
we were there only 20 minutes.
And what happened
is when we landed
we stirred up the
bottom sediment.
And that happens on every
dive, but the subtle currents
of the sea floor move it away.
By the time you've tidied up the
cockpit, filled in your logs,
called topside, tell
them where you're at,
and get the cameras
out, you're ready to go.
In this case it didn't.
It was like being
in a bowl of milk.
And after 20 minutes that
didn't diminish it all.
We had to get back up.
It's winter time, I only
have so many hours in the day
to unhook the tow
from the tugboat.
You've got a 1,200
ton seagoing tug here
and a human hand trying to
hook the Trieste up in a sea
state six.
And so we want to allow
a lot of time to safely.
No use losing a hand or a
life just to do the dive.
And same thing in the
other end of the day.
I wanted two good
hours of sunlight
before we had to go in.
So that kind of described
how long our mission dive
profile would be.
So we got back up in
little over three hours.
Because we don't worry now
about outcrops and all that,
we're just going straight up.
So we could dump a lot of weight
and rocket back to the surface.
And it was a good day's work.
It was nine hours.
Actually the dive I made on
the World War II battleship
Bismarck on one of the
Russian Mir submersibles,
that's 14 hours.
Now that's a drama.
You've really got to plan
your day, if you will,
because they don't have
bathroom facilities.
This is my first
writing triumph.
I wrote that cover
story and it's never
gotten that good since.
52 years and I'm
not in New Yorker,
the magazines that
pay a lot of money.
This one was pretty good.
That's me there.
That's Jacques
trying to figure out
how to inflate his life jacket.
Well he was seasick
and he was trying
to avoid putting
any large objects
into the inflating pipe.
Anyway, sea state was about
eight when we got back up.
I was pretty
relieved to be back.
And we were sitting here.
You know when you
had a bad dream
and you wake up and just
for a fraction of a minute
you don't know if
that's now or then.
Then you realize, oh, I
didn't fall off that building.
And so we got back
up, we climbed
topside and nobody's there.
Now we're 200 miles from land
sitting on a sort of a log,
a sea state eight, and
there's nobody there.
Well of course
immediately I knew better.
Our height of eye was so low
that the ships were there,
we just couldn't see them.
Furthermore, I'd gone to the
Air Force base the previous week
and told what we were doing.
They gave me an
emergency beacon and they
had their search and rescue
aircraft orbiting the area.
So it was fine, but it was just
that little twitch, you know?
The end of a perfect day.
And Jacques and I
were sitting there
waiting to be picked up to
go back to the mother ship
and we were discussing, when
will somebody be here next?
And we finally
settled on two years.
Well, we were wrong
by half a century.
It was 52 years later
when Jim did it.
That was another good
day at the office.
They took us back to Washington.
Remember the old
saying about success
has a million fathers,
whereas failure is an orphan?
Well once we did it,
everybody was telling us
how they've had
every confidence.
We didn't get any
cards and flowers
from those dudes for the
nine months we were on Guam.
When the hull broke,
I didn't bother
to tell my masters at San
Diego, because they would just
pull the plug on
whole operation.
You remember Nelson's blind eye?
Ever hear that saying
that he was in a formation
attacking the French
ships and the lead admiral
in another part of
formation had signaled
Nelson to get behind him.
They were all going
to go like this.
And he held up this
telescope and his flag
captain Hardy said,
well Admiral Nelson,
that signal says you've
got to get back here.
And Nelson had one blind
eye from previous combat,
I think was in Denmark.
So he's holding to
his blind eye and he
says, I don't see
the signal, Hardy.
Proceed as I have ordered.
Well this was not
Nelson's blind eye
that I decided not
to tell San Diego.
They thought we were
a bunch of young guys.
They just left us alone.
They didn't understand
what we were doing.
And I didn't pretend to add
to that lack of understanding.
That is, add knowledge to it.
But after we got back
up in Washington,
we were heroic, all the
admirals and the captains
up on the hill.
I had 150 American flags I
took with me, handing them out
like trading beads
to the Indians.
Appreciate your vote.
I hope you'll take care of
the Navy's Undersea Research
Program, blah, blah, blah.
Anyway, that's what that flag
is that the president's holding.
Good day's work.
We had one stowaway.
Rolex had configured
a special deep sea
Rolex which rode on the outside.
So the pressure at the sea floor
was eight tons per square inch.
They made five of them.
The first two didn't make it.
They tested them to 50,000
foot equivalent depth.
But this one did.
They call it the old lady.
You can see how they got
around the idea of the crystal
by making this big
acrylic wart on top.
They now call it the
old lady because they're
very proud of that.
I didn't know about it.
Piccard-- I went down to the
cabin first, then he came down
and he tied it off
to one of the rungs
in the ladder in
the entrance tube.
And then when we got
back to the surface
he went up first
and took it off.
And if he had asked about that
I would have never permitted it
because this is a US
government operation.
We don't endorse any
private enterprise.
In fact, National Geographic
was irritated at me
for a half century.
That's why the Hubbard
Medal came 50 years later.
They gave us a lunch when
we got back to Washington
to see the president and a
couple of warm handshakes
and a lifetime subscription
to the magazine
and shoved us out the back door.
So it took them a half
century to get over this,
and to award the medal.
Because I think it
was one better things
that happened that year.
And so I wouldn't
even take their flag.
That's how, I don't
know, religious I
was about the whole thing.
I figured I'm a government
employee, a Naval officer.
The whole program belongs to
the people of the United States,
not to Rolex, or National
Geographic, or whoever else.
Unlike some of the
astronauts, they
took golf balls and all
kinds of things to the moon,
but I just didn't
think it was right.
AUDIENCE: They were
in the Air Force.
DON WALSH: They were
Those of you in the Air
Force realize the first thing
they do is they
build a golf course
and then they go to
Congress and say,
well we need money
for the runways.
But anyway, that's
another story.
Anyway, so I didn't know
about this until about two
years later I saw it in
one of these comic strips.
They used to have,
and maybe they
still do, comic
strips [INAUDIBLE],
Science Today or
something like that.
Factual, but it's
all little drawings.
And I saw something about
the deepest diving watch.
I look at this with
some fascination
because there was a little
drawing of the Trieste
and a watch as the next frame.
And I thought, Jesus, I
didn't know about that.
And I should have guessed it.
I'm pretty naive
because a few months
after we made the deep
dive a package comes to me
and it's a Rolex watch.
It came from
Switzerland and it said,
Mr. Piccard suggested you ought
to have one of our watches.
Well, that's pretty nice.
So I didn't think
about it any more.
It's a good story that they
built a special watch that
could stand all that pressure.
It gives some idea
of their engineering,
their excellence in testing,
and blah, blah, blah.
It's pretty good branding.
And yet, if that's such a
good story, why wasn't it
in Piccard's book,
"Seven Miles Down".
He didn't put it in there.
He said nothing about it.
And so clearly he knew
he was doing wrong.
And besides, he was
just a consultant to us.
He had no ownership,
stake in the thing.
He's a dear friend.
He's deceased now.
He died in November '08.
But he made a mistake
there and could
have got me a lot
of trouble if it
had become general knowledge.
Because you're the captain of
the ship and you run aground.
Whether you're in your
cabin or whatever,
you're going to get some on you.
It's just not good.
OK, well that's a long
story, that thing,
but let's move ahead here.
In 1963 the Trieste was
retired at the age of 10.
It was beat up.
It was a flying machine.
Its days were ended.
It's in the Navy Museum
in Washington, DC.
If you're ever in
Washington, DC go down
to Washington Navy Yard.
A cab will take you there.
The best way to do it,
get through the. gate.
And it's a wonderful museum.
The Trieste is all
put back together
looking a lot better than
this, but the same kind
of coloration way in the back.
And there's some nice
descriptive stuff in the back.
Another Trieste was built here
at Mare Island, San Francisco
Bay Naval Shipyard.
Trieste II.
And that was
operated until 1984.
So for 26 years the only
way you could get scientists
into the deepest
part of the oceans
was either with a Trieste
or the French Navy's
bathyscaph Archimedes,
or Archimede.
They're all replaced then
by 20,000 foot submersibles.
Why is 20,000 feet important?
Well it's because if you
look at a chart of sea floor
area versus depth, you
find that at 20,000 feet
you can look at 98% of the
sea floor in the world ocean.
So that's roughly a little more
than half the maximum depth
of the ocean.
So cost benefit, huh?
You build a submersible,
design it for that depth,
and you can get 98%
of the sea floor.
That last 2% is between
20,000 feet and 36,000 feet.
Having said that, last 2%, as
I said last week in Shanghai,
that's equivalent to
the area of China.
So it's worth exploring.
Those are the deep trenches.
If we understand the fundamental
plate tectonics of the ocean
floor, you've got
spreading centers
where new sea floor
is being created.
200 million years
later it's disappearing
into the deep trenches,
the subduction zone.
We don't know much about
the subduction zones.
The spreading center
has been studied a lot
because there are
mineral resources there,
the smokers, the
hydrothermal vents.
I dove one of those
off the Azores
and your water depth's
about 9,000 feet there.
It's not bad.
Very interesting seeing
this whole life form.
It's like visiting
another planet.
That life form doesn't
even know about the sun.
It's getting all of its energy
from the interior of the earth.
Thermal energy from the
interior of the earth.
AUDIENCE: Were you diving
with Robert Ballard?
DON WALSH: No I wasn't.
I know Bob, but no, this
was actual hauling tourists.
I was working with a company
called Deep Ocean Expeditions,
and we could take
into the Titanic.
Took over 80 people there.
About two dozen to the
Bismarck and nearly a hundred
to hydrothermal
vents in the Atlantic
and off the East Pacific Rise.
No, Bob wasn't with
us on that one,
but it's really fascinating.
Usually halfway
through these dives
we sit down at some nice
site, get out our Russian box
lunches, have lunch and
then resume the dive.
The Titanic's a 12-hour dive.
So it's hour six we land on
the bridge of the Titanic,
Captain Smith was last seen.
Turn on Yellow Submarine on the
player and have our sandwiches.
And same thing with Bismarck.
14-hour dive.
Seven hours we land not far
from where Hitler visited.
You've got pictures of Hitler
going aboard in the Baltic.
And in the hydrothermal
vents, sitting right next
to one of these
smokers, watching
all of the animal life.
It really is like you've
been on a spaceship
because you come from
this photosynthetic world
that we know up here down
to this place in the pitch
blackness.
And then you come in
there, turn the lights,
and here's just like visiting
a great big party going on.
There are shrimps, and
there are the crabs
that are catching the shrimps
that get in the hot water
and become scampi,
the whole thing.
It's great.
Anyway, I diverge.
So that's pretty good.
I think you're
getting the point.
That's not an argument not
to have some deep probes.
Now in my view,
the heavy lifting
is going to be done by manned
and unmanned vehicles, AUVs,
ROVs.
But there will always be room
for man-- manned submersibles--
for several reasons.
From the imprecise because--
like you tell your kids.
Why can't I do this?
Because.
To the advantage of having the
trained mind and the trained
eyes in there in certain areas.
Yeah, OK, you say, Well ROVs got
the trained mind and eye there.
It's just throwing
them both a TV camera.
Yeah, but this is the view.
You've all done scuba
diving or snorkeling.
Your face mask, you don't
have peripheral vision.
And there's a lot to be said for
that, in just having the human
there.
But more so, when we put
the first Lunar Lander up
and it brought back some
samples from the moon,
I didn't go out on my
deck and look up there
and say, well done.
But when Buzz and Neil were
up, I went out and I said,
there's two of me up there.
I can connect with that.
And don't ever disallow that
because the money valve is not
in your offices, it's on
Capitol Hill that directs money
to things we want to do.
And it's the public,
an ocean aware public
that will insist that we make
national investments there.
Very nice to go to Mars.
I hope I'm not offending
anybody, but it's like Nero.
Rome is burning.
Here we are looking at
Mars and the water's
coming up around our ankles.
There are some
real things we have
to do on this manned
satellite we all
live on called planet Earth.
So in getting man under the
sea, there's that kind of thing
you can't quantify, but you
can say it's pretty important.
Jim said it's succinctly last
year just after his dive.
He said, what kid wants
to grow up to be a robot?
Well OK, to get
involved in this stuff,
designing and building robots.
I'm not offending
anybody, I hope.
But also personal
participation, pretty important.
Not all of us, that's for
sure, but it's still important.
People like us
doing these things.
OK then this is just a catalog
of some of the 6,000 meter,
or 20,000 foot submersibles.
The first was the Navy's Alvin.
That was upgraded from
6,000 foot submersible
to 20,000 feet.
It's retired.
It's at Woods Hole now.
Next France came along
with the Nautile.
Still operational.
Uses a titanium pressure hull.
The Russians, the
Mir 1 the Mir 2.
As you probably know Mir is
the Russian word for peace.
Plus their Navy has the
Russe and the Consul.
And I've made quite a
few dives in the Mirs.
They're very good subs.
Actually they were
built in Finland
because the Soviet shipyards
were too busy building warships
so they jobbed out, as they
did with their research ships
and so on.
Most were built in
Eastern Europe or Finland.
So the two Mirs were
built in Finland
by a company no
longer in business.
I don't know if there's a
cause and effect or not.
Japan came in a bit later with
their Shinkai 6,500 meters.
So that's 21,000 feet.
So now Japan had the deepest
diving manned submersible
in the whole world.
And a few years before
that I taught the Japanese,
through my consulting company,
how to drive submersibles.
So I have kind of paternal
relationship with this project.
And now of course
we've got China.
That's the money shot.
You probably recall
2007, the Russians
using the Mirs to put a Russian
flag at the real North Pole.
There's a story behind that.
I won't go into it, but
they didn't pay for it,
they didn't plan it,
they just hijacked it.
They took all the credit for it.
So that's what call
the money shot.
That's the bow of the Titanic
is another money shot.
And here's the sub.
7,000 meters.
Now China has the deepest
diving manned submersible
in the world, Jiaolong.
And I've been
consulting with them.
[INAUDIBLE], their
ship research center,
it's like our David Taylor
Center in the United States.
Ship design, ship
machinery, and so on.
Tow tanks.
But they got the job
and their government
to design and build and
test and operate this sub.
And it's very nicely done.
First manned submersible
ever built in China
and they pretty
much got it right.
But it took them 12 years.
They did a nice conservative
job of evolving and developing
this thing and it's
operating very well now
in support of their
interests-- their governments
interests in ocean mining
OK, four programs right now.
They're doing the
deep diving thing.
Of course you you're all
aware of Jim's program.
I was on his
expedition last year.
He did a smart thing.
Look at the direction that
this submersible's going.
It's vertical, isn't it?
Not horizontally.
But all the
submersibles I've shown
you are oriented horizontally
so when you're going down you've
got some resistance.
Hydrodynamically
not the best shape.
He uses a spar buoy.
That's the direction of travel.
It's a very efficient
diving shape.
The water line on this
thing is about right there
when it's on the surface.
Heaps of batteries in here,
lithium cell batteries.
12 thrusters.
The actual spherical
cabin is right there.
Then there are arms that poke
out with TV cameras and lights.
As you can imagine, Jim had
the best of cameras on there.
Shooting 3D, by the way.
And then the same thing,
you get to the sea floor
and they want to come back
up, these are steel weights
that he can shuck off and
the sub comes back up.
When he made his dive
in April of last year,
he got to the sea floor, I
think it was in 90 minutes
and he got back
up in 70 minutes.
And he spent two or three
hours on the sea floor.
It's a very efficient
way of doing things.
Here are the two subs in scale.
His on the right, of course,
and mine to the left.
And I had the good opportunity
to be the last person
to see him before he dove
and the first person when
he came up.
That's Suzy, his wife, there.
And all I said was,
good luck and have fun.
And we came back up I
said, welcome to the club.
There's just two of us in the
world now, it's myself and Jim.
But it was nice, you know?
Half century.
I never thought
I'd see this again.
So it was quite an honor
to be part of his program.
Actually I signed a
non-disclosure agreement
with him in '93 when he
first started this project,
but he didn't tell me
much over those years.
And it was only the
beginning of last year
that I got heavily
involved in this program.
So there you see it
floating vertically
in its normal
operating position.
Zodiac boat up there, divers.
They put in the water
with salvage bags.
These are like inflatable
balloons, if you will,
that are hooked to the side.
Because it's launched
horizontally, than it
erects into the
vertical position.
There's the viewport
that he's got,
two cameras and light
booms sticking out.
And then they cut these free
and the sub starts down.
Those were not stowaways.
Rolex decided, well
half a century later,
let's demonstrate consistency,
engineering excellence, design,
blah, blah, blah.
And look at what they did.
I think this is remarkable.
Flat crystal.
The pressure on that thing,
eight tons per square inch.
They tested at 50,000 feet.
They made five of them,
of all five passed.
All five went to Guam with Jim.
And there it is on the wrist.
That's his manipulator.
There's the watch right there
on the wrist of the manipulator.
National Geographic and
Rolex were the two sponsors.
They may have been in for about
$30 million, I'm not sure.
The sub made 16 dives, so
the unit cost per drive
is-- brings tears to your eyes.
And there we are comparing.
They brought one of the
old ladies out to Guam.
So I've got the replica of the
old lady here, a model of mine.
There's his in the shipping
position, horizontally.
And there's his new watch.
And there being launched.
You can see the salvage
bags, the pillows here
that help it float.
And then they cut
these loose and then
it erects into the
vertical position.
He gave it to Woods
Hole I don't believe
it's going to operate again.
They keep claiming that it will.
He gave them an
endowment of $1 million,
but Woods Hole risk
management people
aren't going to let any of their
scientists dive in this thing.
Because in my view, with
all due respect Chris,
I think one person subs are
a dead end line of evolution.
Multitasking, we all know,
doesn't work so good.
There have been
psychiatric studies where
it shows if you
try and multitask,
your efficiency goes
down between 20% and 30%
of both things
you're trying to do.
And so to fly these
things is a full time job.
And to be a scientist,
full time job.
If you take one of these
things and you kit it out
with all kinds of
remote instrumentation
and samplers so the pilot has
to fly, what have you got?
You've got an AUV
with a man in it.
Where's the game?
I don't see it.
Maybe Chris will be able
to convince me someday.
And here he is, folks.
Hold your applause.
Richard Branson and
Chris got together.
Chris actually bought
the sub and then
talked Richard into joining him.
That's before the divorced.
And then this is basically
an underwater flying machine.
Graham Hawkes, the inventor
up in Richmond, California
came up with this original
concept of deep flight.
My Japanese friends
call it Deep Fright
and I don't know if that's
just a speech impediment
or is Freudian.
I haven't quite
figured that out.
But anyway there is
flying underwater.
This is pretty much
what it will look like.
Another drawing of it.
The pilot lies down.
This is the axis of
the cabin itself.
So it's a cylinder with a
transparent dome on this end
and a solid dome on the other.
Batteries and all the other
stuff in the back here.
Propellers, flight
controls, and so on.
And you can see Chris
is a very large person,
and so when he gets
into that thing,
they have to take a
slight vacuum to pull him
into the tube and
then pressurize it.
It reminds me of those
things in the circus,
you know, the cannon where
you fire the guy out.
We strap him down, so
when they pressurize
the inside to get him out,
he doesn't go too far.
There's another
company in Florida,
Vero Beach, Florida,
called Triton,
and they're going to go
with a glass pressure hull.
And there's a company in the
San Diego area called Rayotek
that has figured out a scheme
that you can use glass and keep
it from being scratched.
Because as we all know,
any scratch on glass
is a stress concentrator
and that's not a good idea.
Whereas with acrylic, you
can sandpaper it and gouge it
with a knife and
you're not going
to compromise its integrity.
You may not be able
to see too well,
but it's not going
to be weakened.
But you scratch
glass, immediately
you've got a stress
puncture and a real problem.
Glass, of course, gets
stronger with depth.
So there's a lot
to be said for it.
Theory and practice, folks.
My first remark
when I started out.
Laboratory curiosity.
Apparently Rayotek, the
company down in San Diego area,
figured out a way that you
can do it that will work.
So stay tuned.
I was told a month ago
that the Triton Submarine
company has gotten
initial funding.
So they're moving
ahead with this.
And finally, the
fourth one is China.
They call this the
Ocean Challenger.
Could be probably 2020.
They're trying to get into
the next five year plan.
And this will be an
11,000 meter submersible.
Here are the specs.
Nothing particularly different.
Two people, except
that's not three but two.
Weight and so on.
That's really not
worth focusing on.
So there it is.
That's the mantra of the day.
Taking the trained mind
and the trained eyes
into the great depths.
However, there have
been unmanned vehicles
that have been down to the
Challenger Deep, the deepest
place in the ocean.
The first was Kaiko, the
Japanese word for trench.
Went down in 1995 and 1998.
Quite successful.
Regrettably, on a shallower
dive on the slopes of the Japan
trench, the umbilical
came up with no vehicle
on the other end.
It somehow got away.
Now all of these
vehicles are kitted out
with strobe lights, acoustic
beacons, radio beacons,
everything you can think
of and bright yellow paint.
No one's ever found it.
My theory is that
there's a fishing
village on the coast of
China, and the head man
has this most
interesting coffee table.
That's why he's head man.
He's got something
nobody else has got.
And it makes very agreeable
noises and lights,
discotheque sort of thing.
Because it would have floated.
And it would have
floated somewhere.
No one's ever seen it.
AUDIENCE: What if
Godzilla ate it?
DON WALSH: Well Godzilla
may have done that.
Maybe we get one of the
puppies if it mated with it.
The thing here is that was a
14 kilometer fiberoptic tether.
Very expensive, very
exotic to build.
In fact, they had to
build two of them.
The first one they
didn't quite get it
finished and it was flawed.
And so they just re-terminated.
So I think it's maybe a
26,000 foot submersible now.
It can't go the full
depth because they
had to chop off part of it.
They built a new vehicle.
That was a $17 million problem.
Now the next and the
last one was Woods Hole,
where the HROV, Hybrid ROV.
It can be an ROV tethered or
it can be an AUV untethered.
And so at the lower
right hand side
you see the final
version of the Nereus,
which is what they called it.
And I think was 2009 when it
dove to the Challenger Deep.
And it seems to be a
pretty good vehicle.
Right now working off Eric
Schmidt's ship, Falkor,
in the Caribbean.
So it's being kept busy.
I don't know if they're
going to go back
to Challenger
Deep-- if and when.
I'm not on their mailing list.
That's it, folks.
I came out right on an hour
because we started five minutes
late.
You may be thinking, jeez, this
guy never comes up for air.
I give you back one minute.
Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So I just
wanted to thank you very much,
Don, for coming.
And maybe we can take
a couple of questions
for those who can stay.
DON WALSH: Yeah, I'm
not put off by people
getting up and walking out.
I've been doing this for a long
time and I'm quite used to it.
I did a high school
in Tyler, Texas once
and I asked the principal
how long, he told me.
And I thought, OK,
I'll stick right on it.
It's like salami, you just
slice off as much as they need.
But about halfway
through a lot of bells
rang and my whole audience
got up and walked out.
It was the end of
the school day.
They had their priorities.
That's why they're in Texas.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Is it an
incremental challenge
to go from 20,000 to 35,000
feet engineering wise,
or is there something that
comes up at 25,000 feet
that requires a whole
different approach?
DON WALSH: His question was
is it an incremental challenge
to go, say, from 25,000
to 35,000, 36,000 feet.
In my view, no.
I ask Woods Hole about that
when they're upgrading Alvins.
You may know Alvin
is being upgraded
from 14,500 feet, something like
that, too about 24,000 feet.
It'll be the second deepest
diving manned submersible.
Thing is, they got
Lockheed Martin involved
and all the money got spent.
So what you've got now is
you've got a 24,000 foot
cabin in a 14,000 foot sub
because all their peripherals--
because you have other
pressure vessels in there
for the batteries
and controllers,
and things like that.
And they couldn't
upgrade the whole sub.
And probably syntactic
foam, I don't know.
But anyway, they spent
the whole $25 million
or whatever it was and never
got the thing finished.
I suspect some year
they'll do that.
But I asked them about this.
Well, why not just
go the full depth?
You don't have to
do it every day,
but if you want to go
into the deep trenches
you've got the capability.
Because most of
the deep trenches,
between 28,000 and
36,000 feet, there's
not that much difference between
the deep places in the ocean.
And that would be an awfully
nice capability to have.
And they said, well ho
and hum about technical,
and we can't-- I listened to
what they said and I still
can't see the difference.
Your problem is pressure.
You've got to make a
robust hull, you've
got to have electric
power, whether it's
for 25,000 or 36,000 feet,
you want as much as you get.
And with these new batteries
that are coming out-- again,
that's the march of material
science-- you can do that.
So that's a constant.
The only delta I can see is
the thickness of the hull.
Titanium, something like that.
I don't understand
it, so I say no.
There's no real difference.
It will be cost difference.
And of course every one of
these has to have a mother ship.
It's even better if you have
a dedicated mother ship.
The two Mirs have a
ship called the Keldysh,
that's all it does.
Basically Atlantis, they claim
it's an oceanographic ship,
but it's pretty much
dedicated to Alvin.
By the way, they're
in San Francisco now,
or maybe San Diego.
Before they did the sea
trial on the new hull,
they just sent it all out here.
And they were in
Astoria, and then they
were supposed to be
in San Francisco,
and then they're going
down to San Diego.
And sometime along
the west coast here
they'll do their actual
acceptance trials.
Alvin is owned by
the Navy so they
have some pretty high standards
about what they have to do.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: You talked a bit about
going down to the [INAUDIBLE]
and stuff like that
and all the life forms
and all this activity
happening there.
And the minerals and stuff like
that that make it worthwhile.
What about going
into the trenches?
What do you see down there?
And what is it that's so
interesting about going
to those depths?
DON WALSH: It's not going to
be a very satisfying answer.
And that is it's what we
don't know is why we go.
Jim made a very successful
dive in the Bismarck Trench
at Papua New Guinea,
about 27,000 feet.
That's when he
lifted the embargo
on the design of
his sub and what
they were going to do with it.
He didn't want a lot of
press piling in on him.
There were only 30
people in his project.
Also the embarrassment.
When you're a very
high visibility person
and you fail at something,
everybody says, you see,
Hollywood guy showboating
and trying to buy his way in,
and blah, blah, blah.
That's of course not
true in Jim's case.
Nevertheless, at that
dive he brought up
quite a bit of bottom
sediments from that trench.
And we had a staff of, I
believe, 13 scientists aboard.
Mostly from Scripp, and
another ship with us
inappropriately
called Barracuda.
It should have been The Gummy
Bear or something like that.
It was pretty bad.
And so we had biologists,
benthic biologists, geologists,
and so on with us.
And they were really
excited about getting
these sediment
samples of microbes.
They're finding there new stuff
that we didn't know about.
And really keen to go back
to the deepest trenches
and do more of this work.
As far as large
critters are concerned,
probably not because the
further you get from land,
the more sterile the ocean gets.
It's because of
lack of nutrients.
Most of the nutrients
are being flushed--
organic, inorganic
nutrients-- from land.
So the coastal zone,
continental shelf
is where you really
hit pay dirt.
And then a little bit over,
say, the continental crest
down in the deep ocean,
slope into the deep ocean.
So 200 miles off
land, not so great.
Sort of a desert.
There's life everywhere.
You get all the invertebrates.
The shrimps, the jellies, things
like that, and bioluminesence,
when you've got the
light's turned out,
things sparkling away.
But compared to what you see
the coastal ocean it's not much.
There is, as you
probably know, they
did some really
wonderful photography
of the giant squid recently
from a submersible.
Really good stuff.
But just when you think
you've seen it all,
when you've seen
the movie, they've
determined that there is a
colossal squid because they've
seen some of these bits of these
things drift up on beaches.
They haven't seen
one in [INAUDIBLE].
The wonderful imagery they got
recently of the giant squid
was in [INAUDIBLE].
They put out bait
from the submersible
and it came in and took.
And got comfortable
with the lights,
it was just hanging around.
It was really something.
So I think probably a
lot of the discoveries
will be in the microbiology
and microplankton area
and what's contained
in those sediments.
Regrettably, on Jim's
dive in the Challenger
Deep-- and it's Murphy's Law.
He had just started to
pick up samples, sediment.
He had core tubes so he could
push them into the bottom,
bring them up, and then
he had a little cupboard
where he could sequester them.
Because as you come back up,
you've got a lot of turbulence
around the sub.
And you just flush it all
out so you lose your samples.
So that was all designed into
that to protect this stuff.
And he was just reaching
out for another one and one
the hydraulic hoses broke.
Now arthritis sets in,
the manipulator's here.
He can't shut the door to
the cupboard, if you will,
and he can't take samples.
And it was is a $50 hose that
screwed up a billion dollar
project.
We see it all the time
in the space program.
Standard stuff.
Pressure tested,
qualified by the vendor,
and tested again by
Jim and his team.
Just a simple hydraulic hose.
And that crippled that mission.
Then due to
programming errors, he
had 12 thrusters and
11 of them shut down.
So all he could do is circle,
make circles on the sea floor.
And that was it.
So it was not a very
productive dive.
But the one in Bismarck
trench was very productive.
And what was his name?
Wake up.
The guy at Scripps.
AUDIENCE: Doug Bartlett.
DON WALSH: Doug Bartlett.
Thank you.
Doug's doing some good
work and some of his papers
will be out soon.
And we do hope to go back.
If not with manned
system, unmanned system.
We the ocean community, not me.
I don't know if
that's a good answer,
but the top answer
is we go there
because we don't
know what we'll find.
That's the nature
of exploration.
I define exploration as
curiosity acted upon.
We're all curious about stuff
we run into all the time.
Oh that's interesting,
I wonder how that works.
But if you don't follow up
on it, find out how it works,
why it works, then
you're not an explorer.
I think little
kids are explorers.
We're all genetically
programmed that way.
You see them in their
mother's arms looking around.
When they're big
enough to run around.
they're taking the gum
off the bottom the table
in a restaurant and
they're exploring that way.
But somehow that the hormones
and peer pressures in the teens
beat out of most of us.
A lot of us don't persist as
explores until our adult years.
See I don't use
the term explorer
as climbing the highest
or diving to the deepest.
It's curious people learning
how things work on our planet.
And even if you're
not a scientist,
it's so important to be curious
about the world around you.
Yes sir.
AUDIENCE: What do you see
as interesting developments
in the next 10 or 25 years?
DON WALSH: I think
what we're going
to see is the development
of, sort of the subject
I've been talking about, is
a manned submersible system.
We can't look at these
things as individual units.
It's a whole system.
That's the mother ship.
You should have an ROV along
that has the same depth
capability so if the
sub gets in trouble
you've got on-board assistance.
The model that appeals to me is
the deep sea drilling project
where a specially
configured drilling
ship is doing these very
deep geological cores all
over the world ocean.
World Ocean Drilling Program.
And that ship was built by
the United States, operated
by the National
Science Foundation.
But we sell tickets
to any investigator
that wants to use it.
So even during the Cold War
we had Soviet geoscientists
out on the ship because
they could buy certain legs.
You publish the ship's schedule
a year or two in advance
and then if that's an area
where you really want to work,
you apply to get
time on that ship.
I can see that model for a full
ocean depth submersible system.
Of course you couldn't do
anything less than that,
but it would be a live-aboard
mother ship, an ROV system,
and other required
scientific instrumentation.
And it would be available
as an international asset.
I don't think you'd
need more than a couple
of systems of that sort
to do the trenches.
You don't have to have one,
every country has to own it.
Just like the deep
sea drilling ships.
Pretty much that one
system was the only one
for 90% of the life
of this program.
Now Japan has one called
Chikyu and the Russians
keep promising to build one,
but it never seems to happen.
So there's at least
two in the world now.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: India has one.
DON WALSH: India has one?
Well, it probably ran
aground somewhere.
AUDIENCE: No.
Beautiful. [INAUDIBLE] built
it, so there are three.
DON WALSH: Is that right?
OK, three of them.
India And with respect
to investigating
the deep trenches, the
thing we're not doing now,
I still think there's going
to be a lot of heavy lifting
that's going to be done
by unmanned vehicles.
The problem here is that
if we agree that about 90%
of the world ocean is
unexplored in terms
of having pretty complete
knowledge of this environment,
that's a big job left to do.
There is not enough money
and all the treasuries
of the world to bill
fleets of research ships
that can undertake that
90% of the world ocean.
And even if you could
build that many ships,
there's not enough
universities in the world
that you could populate them
with trained scientists.
So how do we get around that?
And I think any AUVs,
autonomous unmanned vehicles,
machines that can
do dumb science.
That is, where you don't
require a human presence.
You save the ships
for the kind of work
requires human presence
at the work site.
So I think that AUVs
that can be programmed
to do surveys, data taking
over long periods of time
autonomously.
We're talking months,
maybe, on a mission.
Coming up, transmitting,
data, satellite, back down.
You could probably do that.
In fact, one of Eric
Schmidt's companies,
[INAUDIBLE] Rick Rakowski
there has actually
calculated how many AUVs
he feels could do the world
ocean, that 90%. 's pretty
exciting stuff, isn't it?
That these little satellites
all over the world ocean
gathering this data.
Because we can handle the data.
Modern computational
systems can handle it.
It's just actually getting those
numbers and bringing them in.
And I think that's pretty
exciting next 10 to 20 years.
Chris, can you
briefly say briefly
say what you see the
next 10 or 20 years?
CHRIS WELSH: Hopefully our
project is going to open up.
DON WALSH: Oh dear.
MALE SPEAKER: Say
what he's doing.
DON WALSH: Tell us what
you're doing, Chris.
CHRIS WELSH: You saw this,
Don, but the one thing
I think we bring to the
table that's unusual
is 20 kilometers of
range on the sea floor
once we get down there.
So that's a lot more exploration
than we're capable of doing.
Beyond that, though,
I would agree with Don
that the autonomous
and ROV world
is what it's going to be
because of the dollars.
You can do so much
more with AUVs.
One thing, we talked
about it, but satellites,
drones, all that, you have
full satellite communication.
[INAUDIBLE] high bandwidth.
Down there, full ocean depth,
you're talking sub-2,000
bandwidth.
It's nothing.
So you're text messaging
your controls to your AUV.
And you're not
getting back video.
You're not getting
back pictures.
It's a much more challenging
AUV problem than a drone
because you can't jump in and
repurpose it immediately and do
things you'd like to do.
The physics of that are
not going to get better.
And the fiberoptic
links are as complicated
in and of themselves as the AUV.
So do you want to try and have
a fiberoptic length on that--
IPHONE: I don't know
what that means.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS WELSH: Anyway, so having
an AUV that's really bright
is the key.